Peter we are here you are about to have
night one at the mansion how crazy is
that I know this is crazy yet to pinch
myself right now this is gonna be a very
beautiful night I've been looking
forward to this for a while and I'm just
ready to get this this whole adventure
gone this journey gone it cannot wait to
meet the ladies and you know hopefully
as a very special one stepping out up
one of those limos so are you nervous
yeah there's definitely nerves but
they're good nerves you know means that
you know this means a lot to me and but
this is gonna be a night I know none of
us will ever forget and I just want to
make the most of it and I'm gonna use
those nerves it's good nervous energy so
you promise to give viewers one of the
best love stories they've ever seen yeah
how do you know you can keep that
promise how do you know cuz it you fall
hard or what is it a little bit of that
yeah I am I just it's no secret now I am
one of the biggest romantics you'll ever
meet I to me I've just always growing up
been that person that has always
wondered you know what is my future wife
doing right now like currently right now
I know she exists what is she doing and
that's just the way I've lived my life I
I've never been one to settle to just
you know settle for anything that I know
is not that ultimate you know fierce
type of love and I've seen what my
parents have they've been the most
amazing inspiration for me and I just I
know it's gonna happen I know it's
happening tonight so well I mean you
fell hard for Hannah you were left in
tears you're gonna cry a lot this season
I hope not
there's no promises listen I also have
an emotional dude and I am in touch with
my emotions and I can own that and I
also think I mean a real man you can cry
he's not afraid to cry so yes Peter yeah
all right now look you you give us the
emotions you give us the romance you
gave us the windmill I gave you know yes
my question let me ask you how do you
top the windmill you're a pilot do we
take it to the air I think um I think we
try to introduce some ladies to a new
club so if I had my say I do know how to
fly jets and it's a very prestigious
clubs
who knows are you a card-carrying member
of the mile-high not going to disclose
the answer to that yes or no so well I
gotta call you out we saw condoms in the
console do you keep wouldn't that be
appropriate
okay like you said a safe guy you're
safe I have a very safe guy practice
safety everything I do and everything
not gonna stop now so what type of woman
are you looking for mr. romantic I am
looking for someone that just has that
huge heart full of love that's ready to
you know share that with me
because I know I'm ready to share that
with them what about your physical type
physical type I've always been a light
guy always been a like that's like the
number one thing for me you have nice
legs were for sure gonna catch my eye
and then eyes you know yeah okay blondes
brunettes blue green eyes I kind of
blonde brunette I never truly had a type
with that but uh like some nice green
eyes blue eyes I also gotta ask you to
do something a little fun for us okay oh
you know well yeah I gotta ask you one
tough question okay um a lot of people
did critique the level of diversity in
bachelor casting this season you know
people love Mike Johnson I love Mike
yeah so what do you say to those people
who aren't saying we should have had
that first black bachelor it should have
been Mike and it is you instead and
that's a lot to ask of you personally
because it's the old franchise but what
do you say to them totally fair I
totally get where he was coming from hey
I didn't make this decision right I was
very grateful to accept it and move
forward but listen I regardless of race
of you know identity or what not
everybody who's deserving of love okay
I'm not the only person there would Mike
would have been a great bachelor Tyler
could have been a great bachelor they
picked me and I'm very excited and very
humbled and I can't wait for this
journey to begin but you know I know
Mike he's gonna go find love and he's
very deserving of it and you know at the
end of the day um I know it's tough and
it's you know it has to be brought up
but I'm all for diversity
and I'm I'm excited you know for this
for this journey up maybe date some
diverse woman that I haven't dated
before you know I haven't found my
person yet so maybe I just haven't been
dating the right type of person so I
totally get that it's fair all I can say
is I'm so grateful to have this
opportunity and I wish you know Mike
everyone all the love in the world did
you know for a while that you you had
this on lock has it's been a hard secret
to keep I've known for a couple weeks
okay and I thought I had to keep it a
secret for my parents because they
wanted to get like a reaction a January
and that was tough
now I had to go fly a red-eye flight the
day I found out I got it and I was like
how the hell am I gonna do this but it
was like I was the most wired flight
I've ever had yeah I was pretty easy
right we're gonna do the quickest game
and then we're done very quickly first
you're heading into night one you have
to give a message as pilot can you give
a message to your ladies like a pilot
announcement message okay
about how they should be on night one
ladies this is your captain speaking I'd
like to welcome aboard bachelor very
pleased to be your captain tonight
buckle up it's gonna be a bumpy ride but
hopefully we'll end with the nice
greaser of a touchdown welcome aboard
all right this is our game so fast it's
just a quick rapid rapid-fire answer
these for me
number one turn-on kissing my ear that's
crazy
red flag someone's it's too loud yeah we
would not have worked out deal-breakers
deal-breaker is someone that is a
homebody someone that just doesn't crave
that type of adventure someone who
doesn't love flying that's fair to say
right someone that's you know rooting
for a team that's not the Seahawks your
greatest fear in all this greatest fear
that that the respect that I'm you know
gonna show the women is not necessarily
reciprocated in regards how seriously
I'm taking this I know it's a fun
opportunity it's a crazy experience
once-in-a-lifetime but that you know I
may be
you know could be fooled in a certain
way but Hannah was fooled it is what it
is
I hope it doesn't happen again and
Colton was the virgin Hannah was the
Beast
what is Peter what is Peter that's put
on the spot here uh maybe just talk
about what's the vibe of your season
gonna be like how's it gonna be
different than other seasons just pure
just true I'm gonna be myself
and I'm not changing that for anyone you
know what you see is what you get you
know maybe a little bit you know
stealing that from Hannah but that's you
know what I love about hearing what I
respect about here but and I'm ready
just have fun show my goofy side you
know maybe I didn't get to show at all
last season and just make this a very
memorable season and hopefully at the
end of it give everyone that that
romantic story they're all looking for
[Music]